Now that we've taken each of the numbers
and written them in scientific notation,
we've simplified down
to one power of ten.
Let's continue simplifying
this part of our number so
we have one decimal over here.
So looking at two and
four-tenths and one in six-tenths,
what's the largest common factor
that goes into each of them?
In other words,
what can I divide each of them by,
in order to simplify this
part of the fraction?
And also, what's the largest common
factor for three and five-tenths and
the number seven?
Write the greatest common factor for
these two numbers here and
type in the greatest common factor for
these two numbers here.